ryan hello everybody and welcome back to
our python uh raspberry pi and robotics
tutorial video series in this video
we're going to start wiring up this
motor and
get it going so the first thing that
we're going to go ahead and do
is actually wire up our motor here so as
you can see i've already attached
the wheel to this
anyway the leads are right on the edges
here also here and here
and so the first thing that we want to
go ahead and do is go ahead and actually
wire up
these leads
so what you'll want is two wires
these are the wires here i've already
stripped off the ends of the wire
so then what we'll go ahead and do is
with our black on top i'm just going to
thread it through
and
helps if you kind of twist it up a
little bit
here you would solder i suppose if you
wanted
again i just don't really see the point
of soldering it when it's highly likely
that you will just take this apart and
then do the same thing
connect your red lead so i'm just going
to take some electrical tape
put it on here
and then
just wrap it
around
so again the better way to do it would
be indeed to solder it but i'm not going
to do that for now
so that's that
the next thing that we're going to want
to do now is we can actually
we could hook this up to our h bridge so
we might as well go ahead and do that
so come over here and this is our h
bridge
so now you're going to want to get a
small screwdriver of some sort
and
either a flathead or a phillips head
depending on what kind of screws are in
there for you
and you can see that there's like little
screw holes right here and here you
unscrew that and it's almost like a clip
on the inside so when you unscrew it you
stick the wire in then you squirt screw
it down and it kind of holds the wire in
place for you so that's what i'm going
to do i'm going to go ahead and loosen
them
okay
so that's done we can stick the motor
leads into there
so i'm going to put again
over output one i'm going to put my
black
black wire
okay once you've got that one in go
ahead and put your other one in
and when you're done with both go ahead
and give them a good tug make sure that
they are indeed secure in there the next
thing that we want to do is let's go
ahead and plug in our power supply
so uh let me move this kind of out of
the way a little bit i guess we'll leave
this here and just leave the motor over
here um
so on the power supply your power supply
is going to be plugged in uh to your h
bridge only it's going to be plugged in
here where it says vcc then you've got
gnd which is ground and then 5 volts
well 5 volts is for
the power that you get from your pi so
your pi sends a signal through the five
volts which will send the signal to the
battery pack to turn on these motors and
that's how it works
vcc
uh you might also have something there
that says like 12 volts or 12v
vcc just stands for voltage at common
connector
so unscrew
over vcc and wire you might as well just
unscrew
ground and 5 volts just get them all
done
and
get the red into vcc
and you can go ahead and screw that one
in
now ground
we're actually going to use the pi's
grounding as well so that's not this
won't be the only uh cord that goes into
ground so we're actually going to plug
in our pies ground as well so let's go
ahead and do that so
um
i guess i'll move the battery pack over
here for now put the pie here
and now you're going to want to have is
a cord i'm going to use a black one this
is going to be a male to female
but you could also just use any old wire
really
but male to female will be the best one
to use so what you're going want to do
is plug your the female end into your
raspberry pi and anytime you're looking
at a raspberry pi diagram of the gpio
pins
you're looking at it basically
like this okay
so this is right here
pin one
if it would get focused this is kind of
important that you get the right pins
uh so hopefully the focus there we go so
this one right here is pin one when
you're looking at it so like the top
left is pin one
and then you've got pin two and three
and so on
so uh what you're going to want to do is
plug the ground into pin
six
which is the third down from the top
right or
this one right here
okay
so that's the ground for the pie
so we're going to take ground and we're
going to plug that in
and apparently my vcc came out
so from here uh we'll plug in
the power to vcc or 12v depending on
what you have now you're going to take
the ground
uh for your pi and then also the
grounding for
the battery pack and what i'm going to
go ahead and do is just
spin this one around or twirl it kind of
around
the pie's ground
basically so they're stuck together so
then we'll take that and put it into the
ground now what we want to go ahead and
do
is
set up the input and outputs and then
also we need to
wire up the 5 volt signal here
so the next thing that we want to do is
let's go ahead and wire up our
our 5 volt cable so that's going to be
i'm going to use this green one another
male to female
and you want to plug in to the pi's
second pin
so looking at your pi
that is going to be
apparently we can't fit our pi under
here there we go that is going to be
literally this one like the top
uh top right pin
so plug into that one
and from there we plug that into the 5
volt
spot on our h-bridge
now we want to go ahead and do is get
the gpio pins all set up because we've
got everything else that we want now
for the gpio pins i actually have the
strip if you bought the kit the same kit
that i got
you should have this strip and it's just
a strip of female to female
jumper wires but if you don't have that
you can either use converters or do what
i said before about splicing
or
have just four female to female jumper
wires and it will just be somewhat
useful
if you plug them into the exact same
spots that i plug them in but you don't
have to
it's just that your code will have to be
a little slight like slightly different
than my code so it would just be helpful
if you plug them all into the same spots
that i plug
mine into
so
with that where you're going to plug
these in is going to be here on your
h-bridge you've got
inputs and hopefully i can get it to
zoom there we go so you've got input one
down here two three and four and then
you can see on top you've got ena and
five volts and then five volts in e and
b and that's for enable a and enable b
uh you shouldn't have to even touch
those
i've seen some tutorials where people do
stuff with those if you wanted to add
more motors i'm pretty sure that's when
you would start wanting to use those but
for now
we're going to control four motors
two in succession so if you wanted to
control four completely separate motors
uh then i think you'd want to start
tapping into those but for now we're not
even going to touch those so instead
what we're going to do is just plug your
your male to or your female to females
in each of these four there's four spots
there like i said i've got a strip if
you have a strip
then you can use the strip as well so
anyway i'm gonna plug
starting from input one
to input four white
gray purple blue
just for your notes so if you're looking
and trying to figure out how i plugged
mine in okay
once you've got those plugged in on that
end now you're going to want to plug
them into the gpio pins on your
raspberry pi so for me
input 1 which is my white cable i plug
into pin 15 or gpio 22
on the raspberry pi
and so bringing over our pi
it's going to be hard to show both of
these at the same time but i'll do my
best
pin 15 on your pi
is going to be
i guess 8 down
from the top left input 2 is going to go
into pin 13 which is right above that so
i'm going to take my gray
and plug that in right above it
and then from there uh input 3 is going
to go into pin 11 which is 1 right on
top of
13.
and then our input 4 is going to go into
gpio4 which is actually
two above the last one that we plugged
in
so when you're all done
if you were using the exact same colors
i was using
that is what it should look like
hopefully we can get it to
focus in
pretty good all right so again input 1
goes into pin 15 which is eight down
from the top
or six up from the bottom depending on
which way you go
input
two is in pin 13 which is gpio 21
and pin 15 is gpi 22
then
input three is in pin 11 so basically
those three are right together with each
other right
and then you skip one and then input
four is going into pin seven or gpio4
so when you're all done
um that should be everything wired up so
the next thing that we want to do is
actually turn on our raspberry pi
now that you've got everything hooked up
the next thing that we want to do is
come into our raspberry pi
and now we want to actually program our
first script now as i said in the
previous tutorial video you are going to
need
rpi.gpios so if you haven't already done
it do sudo apt get install python dash
capital r capital p lowercase i
dot all caps gpio
uh hit enter and make sure that you have
the most recent version otherwise uh
you're going to run into some trouble i
already have it so we're good
now the next thing we want to do is
let's go ahead and create a directory
called robotics so make dur
robotics
hit enter cd into robotics
now let's go ahead and make our first
robot script so let's go ahead and do
sudo nano robot one dot pi
now what we want to do is import capital
r capital p lowercase i dot all caps
gpio as lowercase gpio and then finally
import time so gpio here uh this is so
we can control our pins and time is so
we can specify the time length that we
want to control the pins now the next
thing we want to do is gpio.set
mode
gpio dot all caps board
now we want to specify the pins that we
want to be using so
we're going to specify pins 7 11 13 and
15 as gpio output pins so gpio dot setup
7 as gpio dot out
and now we're going to the same thing
for 11 13 and 15 so gpio.setup
gpio.out
gpio.setup13
gpio.out and gpio setup
gpio dot
out
okay and now we actually want to program
um
something right we want to use the pins
to do something so as i said with the h
bridge
depending on the type of signal that you
send not only can we make the motor go
but we can choose the direction of that
motor so first let's just do a simple
um
action to make the motor go
and for me each motor is going to
um at least in my frame they end up
facing each other so we do have to kind
of change some things about depending on
you know
what how you set up your frame uh will
vary if you're going to use the same
frame as me then just use the same code
and you can just use the exact same code
i type here anyways and it will make
your motor go so anyway gpio.output
7
true
gpio.output
11 true gpio.output
13 true and gpio.output
15
false
and we want this to happen for
half of a second 0.5
now when we're all done what we're going
to want to do is do
gpio.cleanup
and what this is going to do is stop all
of the signals coming to our pins
because if you don't do gpio cleanup
what's going to happen is even though
you've you know you did a signed sleep
and then it moves on
it's just going to continue going that's
how sleep even works at all right it's
because this is all activated we sleep
for this long then we clean it up so
that's what we're going to do so now
we can control x save yes enter good now
sudo
python robot one dot pi now don't hit
enter just yet make sure your motor
isn't gonna like run over something
um
and when you hit enter it should run
for half of a second
sure enough mine ran for half of a
second
and that's it so hopefully you guys got
your motors
working there
if you have any questions or comments
feel free to leave them below as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions until the next
video which will be
hooking up the rest of our motors and
also
plugging them into a frame
we'll probably do that and then we'll
set up the rest of the motors so anyway
stay tuned for that thanks for watching